one thing sorry to go on a tangent i
just realized [ __ ] kids for roman um
please don't please
not that kind don't play soundpoint
music
one thing that i hope i get less of next
year
the only regret is that i haven't told
these [ __ ] nft companies that email
me every day to [ __ ] off
[ __ ] off stop emailing me yeah we're not
making nft [ __ ] off yeah we all we all
get them and i just it's not just emails
it's tweets as well did you notice on
some of the tweets
it's just like a bot that gets like
retweeted it'll be like you can buy like
i don't know how me tweeting about like
anime tvs or something has anything to
do with [ __ ] nfts it's either it's
either this bot saying hey you can do
something with this nft or it's this one
guy who every tweet is consistently like
hey you should read this one i never i
never got visibly angry in email before
but this one made me like i shouted it
was this one where it says business
invitation from the most anticipated nft
game i've never wanted to hear that
string of words ever and and the fact
that i got that email maybe what the
[ __ ] is an nft game
[Music]
i don't know i don't want it stop
emailing me i hate this [ __ ] bro i i you
know if you if you're into it that's
fine i don't mind but why do they shove
it down our throat because they want
everything because it's next-gen dude
it's next-gen everyone needs to be
up-to-date on that next-gen [ __ ] but no
because because what it feels like is
that this thing is this thing that i
have like very little knowledge about
it's just getting shoved down my throat
right i understand it and i don't like
it i don't even understand and i hate
still hate it i just but it's because of
the [ __ ] that they like the [ __ ]
stuff they say on twitter it's like mind
numbing
twitter since nfts has become somewhat
worse i don't understand how twitter got
worse but like nfts made twitter so much
more annoying and then every goddamn
youtuber is like somehow using nfts for
like scams as well it's all they are so
many youtubers using nfl okay can you
can you explain to to me and perhaps
audience that doesn't know explain it
like i'm five what the [ __ ] even is an
nft so there's there's a there's like a
you're basically buying the the proof
that you own a piece of artwork right
but it's digital right but it's a
digital piece of artworks it's not a
physical piece but in the in the
blockchain which is kind of i don't i'm
not going into that yeah don't go into
it
like on five explaining
like in like proof to the world that
you're but essentially you are paying
for the proof that you own something
okay right that's the most basic way i
can explain it right so you get a token
that can't be replicated to say you own
this thing right so it's like a
certificate of authenticity no that's
exactly what it is right that's that
that's why people are buying artwork
digital artwork for like ridiculous
amounts of money because yeah in in a
sense even though you can
right click and save as that
like like there there is a token yeah or
like a certificate that says you own the
original piece of the artwork
even though even though it's like
digital i'm like that's dumb as [ __ ]
i have friends good friends who uh like
have made a lot of money from it and
yeah that's what they do and they
produce themselves and they you know
it's all for them i don't mind them
doing it i'm not like you can't do it
it's like just this whole this whole
aspect of shoving it down everyone's
it's just the craze right because people
are trying to make money from it yeah so
so the only way to get money and make
money from a lot of the a lot of them
not all of them are scams but there are
a lot of scams as well there are so many
scams and there's like so many uh
scandals and stuff because there's no
regulation or anything so do people like
buy certain nfts and then resell them
yeah
yeah yeah okay so it's like an
investment so it's
well that's how that's how they frame
that's how they phrase it yeah like
there's been stuff like insider trading
where like websites that sell nfts and
showcase them they have like things
there was like one case where um this
thing where they basically promote an
nft every week and the guy one of the
like ceos or something knew which nft
was coming up so he would buy a bunch of
that that type of artwork and then when
it went up he would sell it and make a
ton of money but there's no laws against
it because it's not considered insider
trading because it's cryptocurrencies
yeah the cyberpunk so there's like
there's it's just the wild west right
now and for some people it's great they
love that
it's a place where because because
there's no rules there's no regulation a
lot of people can get scammed a lot of
people can make a lot of money very very
fast um and it's just kind of like a
toxic environment right that's really
bad yeah it sounds like it's so many
scams and i hate the fact that youtubers
have started promoting them and doing it
of course they have of course they are
[ __ ] awful oh i've released my nfg
which is which is like a shame because i
like like i feel like
the the idea and the technology has like
so much potential and now it's just
being used for like really shitty things
basically yeah and you know there's also
the criticism that it's terrible for the
environment and stuff like that and
whatnot how's it terrible for the
environment oh because the oh
god
do i have to go do my own research the
way that like though how the system
works it uses a [ __ ] ton of computing
power to
have the blockchain okay it's quite an
efficient all right yeah in general it
it wastes a lot of energy to to run
these [ __ ] nonsense yeah basically
like some of these cryptocurrencies at
the moment
have as much energy usage as some
countries to run right
yeah yeah yeah yeah
genuinely it's insane like like the like
the network that nfps run on which is
called ethereum i think uses as much
energy as like sweden or one of those
countries
i'm not like i'm not like this boomer
who's like anti-progress and
anti-technology i'm all for like good
technology but it just feels like the
way it's been going is so such a [ __ ]
mess well it's like it's just awful well
because because it's actually been
shoved down my throat i did actually do
like my research and reading into into
this thing because like if there's if
there's this thing like i like to
understand things and i feel like the
problem the problem now is that it's
just so [ __ ] new that yeah nobody
knows what the [ __ ] to do yeah it's the
wild west and i feel like as
as like as the years progress and it
becomes more stable then this could
there is potential for this technology
to be used for something actual good
actually good and it will i i feel like
it this technology will be more
sustainable in the future as well as
cryptocurrencies kind of figure out hey
let's let's build a system that doesn't
like burn the entire amazon rainforest
to get running right but i feel just
right now it is like i'm staying the
[ __ ] away from this oh yeah i'm not
touching it like the the knee
although that's the last thing they want
it does need some kind of regulation in
some sense to stop all these [ __ ]
scams and the reason why i know how many
scams there are is because they always
reach out to us to ask us to promote
them yeah there's so many that ask us to
promote them and this is like this
[ __ ] nonsense it'll be like hey we're
like a badger poop uh nft uh you wanna
and it's like [ __ ] off just [ __ ] off
like it's
are you looking forward to nfts being
added to your favorite video games
i like i i think if it gets to a point
where it's like it's not like [ __ ]
burning the planet and it and it's chill
you know and
and and they it's it's not so scummy
because because like right like i i see
this [ __ ] and i'm just like the cs go
skin community is like salivating right
now oh my god oh my god yeah nft skins
came over but it'll probably get there
so yeah i can see it happening i can
easily see it happening if you having
one of the kind of things i'm just like
so out of the loop with like that kind
of like honestly
like i feel like this is what my grandma
must have felt when vr was introduced
you know it's like where it's just like
i just can't
wrap my head around like i did ask like
i when you said ethereum like i was like
oh okay yeah i've heard of that because
when the first time i heard ethereum i
was like i'm pretty sure you can collect
that in starcraft right like
that's what that's what it sounded like
to me and then i was like oh wait no
it's like a crypto thing okay never mind
i feel very old right now i'm not bad
that's the only trend i hope changes or
dies down yeah that's all i want i don't
care
i'm just i just i just i just want some
actual cool applications that are not
just selling overly priced artwork which
is just the exact same [ __ ] artwork
it's it's it's the amount of times i've
seen that monkey nft like we're just
different skins i don't even know what
that monkey nft is like oh well i've got
the skin boy he's wearing the pirate hat
and it's like [ __ ] off you realize how
stupid this sounds
oh god at least if some guy spends
talking 200 on a monet he's got a
[ __ ] monet but also i don't i don't
think he's good either but yeah this has
got the [ __ ] paintings yeah exactly
didn't burn down the rainforest to get a
[ __ ] token and it's not such a boomer
i know i hate i hate all this stuff man
it sucks i just yeah scams suck too and
yeah again i hope that it gets some kind
of uh i hope that it regulates up its
act
because it stops being so [ __ ] yeah
because like i was reading about up
about like the possible applications
nfts could have and like you know you
know you have a non-fungible
nft stands for non-fungible tokens so of
course right now it's been used as a
certificate to say you own this stuff
but it has like a lot more applications
above that you can think about hey
sending over certification to say hey
this person let's say has a driver's
license or has like
has you know is certified has a master's
degree or something along those lines
where it's like one centralized unit
that anyone can check so we don't rely
on like some companies like forging
driver's license or documentation or
like having to go all the way to like
even thinking thinking about house
ownership or any kind of ownership right
yeah the amount of [ __ ] paperwork or
you know you think think of think of how
much it can revolutionize japan if there
was one system that said this person
owns this and this person owns that
that's like that's like that's got so
much potential to like like
like reduce the paperwork by tenfold
yeah you gotta give japan time they've
just discovered databases so you know
like
china's still using the phone
just discover what excel is yeah like
yeah maybe like 30 40 years time for
that no i i think there is a lot of
exciting things that it could be useful
yeah but right now it is that sounds
cool yeah right like yeah that sounds
like a real life use but you know like i
i remember like the only piece of news i
saw about nft is when it was first
popping up was like the original nyan
cat gif got like sold as an nft for like
some some stupid amount of money and i
was like who what i want to know is who
sold it and how did they prove that they
had ownership of it i think it might
have been the original creator
i don't know i think even like the
original creator was like there's
actually a loophole for this we can't
actually like this concept is actually
not applicable to what yeah that's
that's that's that's the biggest leap so
what we're saying is we can't
authenticate whether it's authentic or
not yeah yeah that's what they said what
the [ __ ]
does that not
there's still a lot about this place i
don't understand so i'm not gonna i'm
gonna i'm only gonna comment on things
that i do know yeah yeah i just want
less scams yeah please
yeah so like for example like a single
ethereal transaction consumes as much
electricity as an average u.s u.s
household uses in a work week and has a
carbon footprint equivalent to 140 893
these are like for example like visa
credit card transactions or 10 595 hours
of watching youtube
what the [ __ ]
that's like every nft transaction that's
because that's [ __ ] insane
thousand hours of watching youtube
why yeah right now right now it is we
truly live in a society
bro
that's actually depressing that's so
depressing to her
[ __ ] what a way to end the year
well happy new year gamers happy new
year
hopefully next year you won't be as
depressed hearing merry christmas if you
celebrate it if not happy holidays if
not have a good day i'm gonna buy an nft
of my favorite fortnight naruto skin
that's what i'm gonna buy god